[Music]
you should consider yourself lucky lease
your balls won't freeze off and take
great defensive dwarf jokes but love
telling unit jerks why is that because I
have balls new Denver last time we spoke
was at Joffrey's wedding miserable
affair had its moments apologies for
leaving like yes it was a bit hard to
explain why my wife fled moments off for
the king's murder I'm sure you weren't
thrilled to hear the Lannister is
marching north you believed her she has
something to live for now I believe she
wants to survive I used to think you
were the cleverest man alive go on
I don't know how to ride a dragon nobody
does until they ride a dragon what if he
doesn't want me till then I've enjoyed
your company Jon Snow
to whatever you can you've completely
ruined horses for me
it's cold up here for a southern girl so
keep your queen yes your grace
a few died in transit they cheated earth
ice maybe I cheated someone cheated in
elephants no elephants your grace
that's disappointing I wanted those
elephants we're going to die at
Winterfell I always pictured myself
dying in my own bed the age of 80 the
belly full of wine and girl's mouth
around my [ __ ]
you overestimate our influence John and
Daenerys don't want to listen to lonely
old man not that old not as old as him
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
almost the big woman's still here so
you're the man
I'm which man am i you create the one
who saved said you're aware no one else
could they could they just wouldn't if
it's not too much trouble I could use a
pardon for what crime um
I borrowed a few books from the Citadel
[Laughter]
some oh I'm sorry I know I'm not
supposed to be down here were you hiding
from me of course not what are you doing
in Winterfell but did you read every
book in the Citadel already
I wish father were here I would love to
see the look on his face when he
realizes the two sons are about to die
defending Winterfell and you no thank
you I should try and get some sleep you
really think any of us against Steve
tonight
[Laughter]
we'll have that drink you're not the
night women can't be nights why not
tradition folk tradition by night you
ten times over
you don't need a king any night can make
another night
in the name of the mother
I charge you to defend the innocent
arise Brienne of Tarth
a knight of the Seven Kingdoms Knights
of the Seven Kingdoms
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]